what I want to do in this video is
explain what a mortgage is but I think
most of us have at least a general sense
of it but even better than that actually
go into the numbers and understand a
little bit of what you are actually
doing when you're paying a mortgage what
it's made up of and how much of it is
interest versus how much of it is
actually paying down the loan so let's
just start with a little example let's
say that there is a house that I like
let's say that that is the house that I
would like to purchase it has a price
tag of let's say that I need to pay five
hundred thousand dollars to buy that
house this is the seller of the house
right here and they have a mustache
that's the seller of the house I would
like to buy it I would like to buy the
house this is me right here and I've
been able to save up one hundred and
twenty five thousand dollars I've been
able to save up one hundred twenty five
thousand dollars but I would really like
to live in that house so I go to a bank
I go to a bank let me get a good color
for a bank so that is the bank right
there and I say mister bank can you lend
me the rest of the amount I need for
that house which is essentially $375,000
I'm putting 25% down this right this
right this number right here that is 25%
of five hundred thousand dollars so I
asked the bank can I have a loan for the
balance can I have three hundred
seventy-five thousand dollar loan and
the bank says sure you seem like a nice
guy with a good job who has good credit
rating I will give you the loan but
while you're paying off the loan you
can't have the title of that house we
have to have that title of the house and
once you pay off the loan we're going to
give you the title of the house so
what's going to happen here is we're
going to have the loan is going to go to
me so it's three hundred and seventy
five thousand dollars three hundred and
seventy five thousand dollar loan then I
can go and buy the house so I'm going to
give the total $500,000 $500,000 to the
seller of the house and I'll actually
into the house myself assuming I'm using
it for my own residence but the title of
the house the document that says who
actually owns the house so this is the
home title this is the title of the
house home home title it will not go to
me it will go to the bank the home title
will go from the seller or maybe even
the sellers bank because maybe they
haven't paid off their mortgage it will
go to the bank that I'm borrowing from
and this transferring of the title to
secure a loan when I say secure a loan
I'm saying look I need to give something
to the lender in case I don't pay back
the loan or if I just disappear so this
is the security right here that is
technically what a mortgage is this
pledging of the title as the as the
security for the loan that's what a
mortgage is and actually it comes from
Old French more means dead dead and the
gage means pledge I'm I'm 100% sure I'm
mispronouncing it but it comes from dead
pledge because I'm pledging it now but
that pledge will eventually die once I
pay off the loan once I pay off the loan
this pledge of the title to the bank
will die it'll come back to me and
that's why it's called a dead pledge or
mortgage and probably because it comes
from Old French is the reason why we
don't say mortgage we say mortgage but
anyway this is a little bit technical
but normally when people refer to a
mortgage they're really referring to the
loan itself they're really referring to
the mortgage mortgage the mortgage loan
and what I want to do in the rest of
this video is use a little screenshot
from a spreadsheet I made to actually
show you the math or actually show you
what your mortgage payment is going to
and you can download you can download
the spreadsheet at Khan Academy Khan
Academy dot org slash downloads
downloads slash mortgage
calculator mortgage are actually even
better just go to the download just go
to the downloads folder and on your web
browser you'll see a bunch of files and
it'll be the file called mortgage
calculator mortgage calculator Q later
dot X LS x so it's a Microsoft 2007
format so just go to this URL and then
you'll see all the files there and then
you can just download this file if you
want to play with it but what it does
here in this kind of dark brown color
these are the assumptions that you can
input and you can change these cells in
your spreadsheet without breaking the
whole spreadsheet so here I have assumed
a five point five percent interest rate
I'm but I'm buying a five hundred
thousand dollar home it's a twenty five
percent down payment that's that's the
hundred and twenty five thousand dollars
that I had saved up that I talked about
right over there and then the alone
amount well I have one hundred
twenty-five I'm gonna have to borrow
three hundred seventy five it calculates
it for us and then I'm going to get a
pretty plain vanila loan this is going
to be a thirty-year so when I say term
in years this is how long the loan is
for so thirty years it's going to be a
30-year fixed-rate mortgage fixed rate
fixed rate which means the interest rate
won't change we'll talk about that a
little bit this five point five percent
that I'm paying on my on the money that
I borrowed will not change over the
course of the thirty years we will see
that the amount I've borrowed changes as
I pay down some of the loan now this
little tax rate that I have here this is
to actually figure out what is the tax
savings of the interest deduction on my
loan and we'll talk about that in a
second you can ignore it for now and
then these other things that aren't in
brown you shouldn't mess with these if
you actually do open up the spreadsheet
yourself these are automatically
calculated and this right here is a
monthly interest rate so it's literally
the annual interest rate five point five
percent divided by twelve and most
mortgage loans are compounded on a
monthly basis so at the end of every
month they see how much money you owe
and then they will charge you this much
interest on that for the month now given
all these assumptions there's a little
bit of behind the scenes
in a future video I might actually show
you how to calculate what the actual
mortgage payment is it's actually a
pretty interesting problem but for a
$500,000 loan well a $500,000 house a
$375,000 loan over 30 years at a five
point five percent interest rate my
mortgage payment is going to be roughly
twenty one hundred dollars now right
when I bought the house I want to
introduce a little bit of vocabulary and
we've talked about this in some of the
other videos there's an asset in
question right here it's called a house
and we're assuming that it's worth five
hundred thousand dollars we are assuming
it's worth five hundred thousand dollars
that is an asset it's an asset because
it gives you future benefit the future
benefit of being able to live in it now
there's a liability against that asset
that's the mortgage loan that's a three
hundred and seventy five thousand dollar
liability three hundred and seventy-five
thousand loan or debt so if you are if
this was your balance sheet if this was
all of your assets and this is all of
your debt and if you were essentially to
sell the assets and pay off the debt if
you sell the house you get the title you
could get the money then you pay it back
to the bank then well actually it
doesn't necessarily go into that order
but I won't get too technical but if you
were to unwind this transaction
immediately after doing it then you
would have you have a five hundred
thousand dollar house you'd pay off your
three hundred seventy five thousand in
debt and you would get in your pocket
one hundred and twenty five thousand
dollars which is exactly what your
original down payment was but this is
your equity and the reason why I'm
pointing it out now is I'm in this video
I'm not going to assume anything about
the house price where there goes up or
down we're assuming it's constant but
you could not assume it's constant and
play with the spreadsheet a little bit
but what I what I'm introducing this
because as we pay down the debt this
number is going to get smaller so if
this number is getting smaller let's say
at some point this is only three hundred
thousand then my equity is going to get
bigger so you can kind of view equity is
how much value do you have after you pay
off the debt for your house if you were
to sell the house pay off the debt what
do you have left over for yourself so
this is really kind of your this is the
real wealth in the house the owners this
is what you own
wealth in house or the actual what the
owner has now what I've done here is
actually before I get to the chart let
me actually show you how I calculate the
chart and I do this over the course of
30 years and it goes by month so you can
imagine and there's actually 360 rows
here on the actual spreadsheet and
you'll see that if you go and open it up
but I just want to show you what I did
so on month 0 which I don't show here
you've borrowed three hundred and
seventy five thousand dollars now over
the course of that month they're going
to charge you 0.46 percent interest
remember those five point five percent
divided by twelve point four six percent
interest on three hundred seventy five
thousand dollars is 1718 dollar seventy
five cents so I haven't made any
mortgage payments yet so I borrowed
three hundred seventy five thousand this
much interest essentially got built up
on top of that it got accrued so now
before I pay any of my payments instead
of holding three hundred seventy five
thousand at the end of the first month I
owe three hundred and seventy six
thousand seven hundred and eighteen
dollars now I'm I'm a good guy I'm not
going to default on my mortgage so I
make that first mortgage payment that we
calculated that we calculated right over
here so after I make that payment then
I'm essentially what's my loan balance
after making that payment well this was
before making the payment so you
subtract the payment from it this is my
loan balance after the payment now this
right here what I have little asterisks
here this is my equity now so remember I
started with a hundred and twenty five
thousand dollars of equity after paying
one loan balance after after my first
payment I now have a hundred and twenty
five thousand four hundred and ten
dollars in equity so my equity has gone
up by exactly four hundred and ten
dollars now you're probably saying hey
gee I made a two thousand dollar payment
a roughly a two thousand dollar payment
and my equity only went up by four
hundred ten thousand dollars shouldn't
this debt have gone down by two thousand
dollars and my equity have gone up by
two thousand and the answer is no
because you had to pay all of this
interest all of this interest so that
very in the beginning your payment your
two thousand dollar payment is mostly
interest all
$410 of it is principled but as you and
then your and then so as your loan
balance goes down you're going to pay
less interest here and so each of your
payments are going to be more weighted
towards principle and less weighted
towards interest and then to figure out
the next line this interest accrued
right here I took my your old your loan
balance exiting the last month multiply
that times 0.46% you get this new
interest accrued this is your new
prepayment balance I pay my mortgage
again this is my new loan balance and
notice already by month to two dollars
more went to principal and two dollars
less went to interest and over the
course of 360 months you're going to see
that it's actual a sizeable difference
and that's what this chart shows us
right here this is the interest and
principal portions of our mortgage
payments so this entire height right
here this is let me scroll down a little
bit this is by month so this entire
height you notice this is the exact this
is exactly our mortgage payment this two
thousand one hundred and twenty nine
dollars now on that very first month you
saw that of my two thousand one hundred
dollars only four hundred dollars of it
this is the four hundred dollars only
four hundred dollars of it went to
actually pay down the principal the
actual loan amount the rest of it went
to pay down interest the interest for
that month most of it went for the
interest of the month but as I start
paying down the loan as the loan balance
gets smaller and smaller each of my
payments there's less interest to pay
let me do a better color than that
there's less interest let's say we go
out here this is month 198 over there
that last month there was less interest
so more of my $2,100 actually goes to
pay off the loan until we get all the
way to month 360 and you can see this in
the actual spreadsheet and month 360 my
final payment is all going to pay off
the principal very little if anything of
that is interest now the last thing I
want to talk about in this video without
making it too long is this idea of a
interest tax deduction so a lot of times
you'll hear financial planners or
Realtors tell you hey the benefit of
buying your house is that it's it has
tagged
advantages and it does your interest is
tax deductible your interest not your
whole payment your interest is tax
deductible deductible and I want to be
very clear what deductible means so
first let's talk about the interest
means so this whole time over thirty
years I am paying twenty one hundred
dollars a month or twenty one hundred
twenty nine dollars and twenty nine
cents a month now in the beginning a lot
of that is interest so on month one
seventeen hundred of that was interest
that seventeen hundred dollars is tax
deductible now as we go further and
further each month I get a smaller and
smaller tax deductible portion of my
actual mortgage payment out here the tax
deduction is actually very small as I'm
getting ready to pay off my entire
mortgage and get the title of my house
now I want to be very clear on this
notion of what tax deductible even means
because I think it is misunderstood very
often this doesn't mean let's say that
let's say in one year let's say in one
year I paid I don't know I'm going to
make up a number I didn't calculate it
on the spreadsheet let's say in year one
year one I pay I pay ten thousand
dollars in interest
ten thousand in interest remember my
actual payments will be higher than that
because some of my payments went to
actually paying down the loan and but
let's say ten thousand went to interest
to say this deductible and let's say
before this let's say before this I was
making a hundred thousand you let's put
the loan aside let's say I was making a
hundred thousand dollars a year and
let's say I was paying roughly thirty
five percent on that hundred thousand I
won't go into the whole tax structure
and the different brackets and all of
that let's say you know if I didn't have
this mortgage I would pay thirty five
percent taxes which would be about
thirty five thousand dollars in taxes
for that year just this is just a rough
estimate now when you say that ten
thousand dollars is tax deductible the
interest is tax deductible that does not
mean that I can just take it from the
thirty five thousand dollars that I
would have normally owed and only pay
twenty five thousand
what it means is I can deduct this
amount from my income so when I tell the
IRS how much did I make this year
instead of saying I made $100,000 I say
that I made $90,000 because I was able
to deduct this not directly from my
taxes I was able to deduct it from my
income so now if I only made $90,000 and
I and this is I'm doing a gross
oversimplification of how taxes actually
get calculated and I pay thirty five
percent of that let's get the calculator
out let's get the calculator so 90 times
0.35 is equal to thirty one thousand
five hundred so this will be equal to
thirty one thousand and five hundred
dollars and put a comma here
$31,500 so off of a ten thousand
deduction ten thousand a deductible
interest I essentially saved thirty five
hundred dollars I did not save ten
thousand dollars so another way to think
about is if I paid ten thousand interest
I'm going to send my tax rate is 35%
I'm going to save thirty five percent of
this in actual taxes this is what people
mean when they say deductible you're
deducting it from the income that you
report to the IRS if there's something
that you actually could take straight
from your taxes that's called a tax
credit so if you're right if there is
some special thing that you can actually
deduct it straight from your credit from
your taxes that's a tax credit tax
credit but a deduction just takes it
from your income and so on this
spreadsheet I just want to show you that
actually calculated in that month how
much of a tax deduction do you get so
for example just off of the first month
you paid $1,700 in interest of your
$2,100 mortgage payment so thirty five
percent of that and I got the thirty
five percent as one of your assumptions
35 percent of seventeen hundred dollars
I will save six hundred dollars in taxes
on that month so roughly over the course
of the first year I'm going to save
about seven thousand dollars in taxes so
that's nothing nothing to sneeze at
anyway hopefully you found this helpful
and I encourage you to go to that
spreadsheet and play with the
assumptions only the assumptions in this
brown
unless you really know what you're doing
with the spreadsheet and you can see how
this actually changes based on different
interest rates different loan amounts
different down payments different terms
different tax rates that'll actually
change the the tax savings and you can
play around with the different types of
fixed mortgages on this spreadsheet